das erste herz aus dem 3d drucker das
ist wirklich ein riesenfortschritt das
gedruckte organ hat alle wichtigen
strukturen wie zum beispiel blutgefäße
und besteht komplett aus menschlichem
gewebe also wie genau funktioniert diese
technologie heißt es jetzt gedruckt das
organ stadt organspende ging es um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich
faszinierendes 1 videos abonniert den
kanal und dann verpasst er nichts
herzlich willkommen und vielen dank für
euren coolen themenvorschlag der aus der
web community kamen das ist eine
premiere denn das herz das mit hilfe
eines 3d druckers erzeugt wurde ist
komplett vollständig dazu tal wir von
der universität tel aviv der an dem
experiment beteiligt war
es ist das erste mal dass ein
vollständiges herzen mit seinem
zellgewebe blutgefäßen und wenn trinken
gedruckt wurde
momentan ist unseren 3d herz zwar noch
klein in etwa so groß wie ein hasenherz
um ein größeres menschliches herz
herzustellen bedarf es aber derselben
technologie mit ventrikel werden die
herzkammern bezeichnet der drei den
druck hat sich im medizinischen bereich
schon als erfolgversprechendes werkzeug
etabliert bislang gelang es
beispielsweise gewebe die menschliche
haut silikonimplantate und sogar
künstliche eierstöcke herzustellen
das große ziel der fachleute auch
komplizierte organe wie beispielsweise
das menschliche herz zu erzeugen
diese könnten an maßgeschneiderten
gerüsten aus dem 3d drucker heran
gezüchtet werden aber von vorne
für ihr experiment nutzen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
aus israel fettzellen die sie aus dem
bauchraum von probanden entnommen hatten
diese zellen wurden dann umprogrammiert
und zwar zu sogenannten pluripotenten
stammzellen dabei handelt es sich quasi
um alleskönner
denn diese zellen sind in der lage sich
in unterschiedliche arten von
körperzellen zu differenzieren für diese
spezialisierten zelltypen wird also die
uhr zurückgestellt das klingt nach einer
spektakulären science fiction story ist
aber in diesem bereich schon seit
einiger zeit alltag für die fachleute
aus den fettzellen wurden dann zum einen
herzmuskelzellen gezüchtet und zum
anderen so genannte endothelzellen die
die blutgefäße auskleiden aber auch
die extrazelluläre moleküle des spender
materials wie beispielsweise kollagen
und glykoprotein wurden sinnvoll genutzt
das israelische forschungsthemen stellte
daraus nämlich ein hydrogel her damit
bildeten die experten und expertinnen
das stützgewebe für das herz beides
gelangen erfolgreich vereinfacht gesagt
entstand dann aus der kombination von
den zellen und dem hydrogel eine art bio
tinte der 3d drucker hat die herzmuskel
tinte und die blutgefäße hinter genutzt
um schicht für schicht eine struktur zu
drucken die einem herzen ähnelt in einem
ersten schritt entstanden dabei gewebe
flicken in der fachsprache auch kardec
patches genannt diese können nach einem
herzinfarkt genutzt werden um
abgestorbene regionen wieder mit
frischen zähnen zu versorgen das team
erzeugte dann in einem zweiten schritt
die organische struktur bestehend aus
herzmuskel mit blutgefäßen
besonders hervorzuheben ist an diesem
erfolg dass dieses gewebe bis auf wenige
ausnahmen komplett aus menschlichem
gewebe besteht und eben auch das
stützende hydrogel aus dem spender
material produziert wurde
und das hat einen entscheidenden vorteil
wenn solch ein organ in den menschlichen
körper transplantiert würde dazu tal wir
die biokompatibilität ist entscheidend
um das risiko einer organabstoßung zu
minimieren
wir präsentieren hier ein gewebe das den
immunologischen zellulären biochemischen
und anatomischen eigenschaften des
patienten vollständig entspricht
dennoch ist auch klar dass es bis zum
klinischen einsatz noch ein weiter weg
sein wird denn auch wenn das herz aus
dem 3d drucker auf den ersten blick
einem menschlichen herzens welt verhält
es sich nicht so denn die zellen können
zwar kontrahieren also sich
zusammenziehen doch sie können sich
nicht synchron zusammenziehen eine
organfunktion wie das pumpen kann diese
struktur also noch nicht übernehmen
dafür müssen die gedruckten herzen noch
weiterentwickelt werden und genau daran
arbeiten die fachleute aus israel
derzeit falls das gelingt wäre das aber
tatsächlich ein entscheidender
durchbruch denn herzkrankheiten gehören
weltweit zu den führenden todesursachen
betroffene wären dann nicht mehr auf
eine organspende angewiesen ihnen könnte
dann ein organ aus dem 3d
drucker aus dem eigenen gewebe gedruckt
weiterhelfen kunst organe aus dem 3d
drucker kunst vagina erfolgreich
implantiert
auch das gab es schon dafür hier
draufklicken anschauen und klicks um
abonnieren falls ihr es sträflicherweise
bisher versäumt haben sollte bis dann
bleibt dran